we have a giant desert pit and I have a
hundred people trapped in this box give
or take a few dozen and I have Chandler
here normally I'd have Chris but Chris
is actually down there competing with
Carl Taylor when you feel ready press
the button all right oh we started thank
you Chris and Carlos screaming right now
oh there's a diamond sword over here I'm
going for it PvP is on for the next 30
seconds starting now someone found the
diamond sword yeah I hid like five of
those
they're already spawning blades is what
the world oh my gosh wait dream get in
there get them get them I hit him yeah
this guy just because all right who is
this oh I see Carl
oh that normally Chris kills Carl
but since Chris isn't here yet Chandler
I had to take over agree I agree that
was the best movie it's the fourth
person dead I mean you could just dodge
the creepers what oh my god I snuck up
behind this guy he has no idea I'm here
let's see if he notices oh he did oh
you're a smart boy in 30 seconds I will
drop stuff lava turned PvP on formation
boys formation I think Chris has a
little [ __ ] cos Inga let's see that's
not Chandler oh it's this kid dude why
this kid Oh dream has almost full
diamond how did he get that Oh
Zomba oh that's unfortunate that's
unfortunate oh that's unfortunate
fatality when I died I TP back in and
kill the guy who killed me okay just
making sure
yeah join our call help us out I am
putting a bounty on dreams dream just
join the server dream how do you like
the bounty on your head I don't like it
but I just killed somebody so this is
dream Channel apparently he's like the
best player in the world he's better
than technically keeps talking about how
much better he is he technically
oh my god
we're not doing this joke again there's
like 15 people actually there was 400 oh
wait they killed you yes
I thought you were better than techno
blade dude what the heck I thought you
were good
who killed him here is right here this
person right here
Dazz nur was the one who killed dream
pvp is now off hello
Daz nur congratulations you just killed
one of the best players in the world and
won $5,000 oh my god before we go back
to the mayhem that is this challenge
what do you want to say you just won
five grand I did not expect to kill him
wait before you leave say that dream
sucks Wow dirty socks please creeper
creeper dream you want to help us kill
people yes let me do that well Oh wrong
button Chris oh my gosh let's see ways
this slowly pulling my ankle no button
wrong button how do I do dude how many
people did you just kill with this no
one okay good good yeah destroy kill the
fish Oh yo here get a new fish oh that's
not a kind of genuine manner alright yo
just withers going crazy on these little
pigs
this guy is a cape which means he went
to mind card only successful
millionaires go to mind con so he
clearly doesn't need the 10 grand yeah
$10,000 is on the line why have we not
been talking about that yeah I just gave
this guy a diamond sword
okay well that diamond sword might win
him 10 grand your diamond sword might
turn into a car whoa it can do that
Oh do anything witness the brutal murder
I just sat there and hit this guy
repeatedly with the try I just one hit
someone on accident then we need more
creepers uh right here take a Ravager
Hey
oh why did you can put a Ravager right
beside you just got a sword good now I
can defend himself from the ravager in
these creepers can we take a moment to
realize how beautiful this math is and
that also we build every map we play on
we are the best channel out there who's
doing it like this I don't think anyone
else makes Minecraft videos all right
well I'm detonating some TNT take cover
boys oh my gosh
Karl Chris Chandler Jim here hello we
got somebody whoa look at this bowling
so here's the deal
Chris do a 360 pick a random direction I
want to slaughter anything that moves
over there go
[Music]
this corner is the bad corner there's
people running into the corner - no we
both killed your two jerks - one can
roam this video Oh guys can I get a
whole yeah girl oh ho ho
Carl it's your turn pick a corner this
one all right which means that corner
over here why can't we hit him I gotta
take the women take the children's the
wither stuck up here we have an alliance
with this corner what are you savages
doing your mom ran into my face but I
didn't kill her 18 people remain and to
get them to do you know some lady died T
I'm gonna drop some items in the middle
no no I made a canyon it's grand come to
the fireworks
we must country stop soon yeah look we
got a beacon they're dropping diamond
boots drone diamond hummons
dropping a diamond chestplate dropping
it down and stored dropping pants Oh bro
there's so much loot down there I think
this one guy right here literally just
got it all guys when I tell you to come
to spine come to smart oh oh he wants
that diamond sword he want that diamond
sword oh my god why'd you hit him hits
me right away like a coward he's a fight
fight fight fight fight space on my
command boo boo boo that you are the
only one
oh he turned on him this guys coming in
it sighs oh wait should we use coming in
for the oh it's quit helping what it's
about to go down well this kid
determined $10,000 on the line for race
coming back guys things are about to get
fun all parades getting it he's going to
duke it out fight fight
no no no to be fair I laid that lava so
David stay and fight not so he would
jump in it you want to know a cool way
to light TNT how come over here and
shoot it through the lava with your try
them oh yeah it lights the tried it on
fire nice I don't have Chui fight fight
the steel all right oh my gosh I stopped
keeping track because Frank was
murdering so many people apparently
there's four people left trapped for a
though let him out let him out no no no
he's not in the lava oh he's on fire
Taylor how do you lay LaVon I have it in
my heart bar and you just accidentally
pressed above his head like seven time I
was trying literally they do his
murderous rampage can I be stopped
well yeah we tried to stop it until
Chandler put lava in and he broke free
and this guy that's hiding is a stone
sword and leather armor and versus like
Goliath this is why we wanted to stop
his free all right we got a trap this
person of death why is he not listening
to us stop moving comply comply comply
stop stop stop stop
that boy I'll do this until 3:00 until
he dies and free win yo buddy yo buddy
buddy I don't want this guy to win
anymore I really don't use e-stop breath
I'm not inviting this guy back to future
events how many people does it take to
trap a chip I don't hit him anymore he
might be low on health all right
parently takes six people to trap this
man stay there I'm just trying to give
you ten grand
all right now sit in the dark no one
likes you I picture a 14 year old just
like me
take their items away and give them all
full diamond armor we're building an
obstacle course for them to Duke it out
for the 10 grand on do you know why TV
both you hear mm-hmm true you've been
here while we built the whole course
we'll just act like you don't know do
you know I brought you here yes know
what just for that I want you to go
first mr. smart guy
we have $10,000 on the line and only one
of you are getting it so this is the
obstacle course
the rules are simple get to the other
side you survive
if you both died whoever makes it the
farthest okay all right for a since you
want to be a wise guy
have at it and first jump okay take your
time take your time take your time
oh okay okay Oh money money he's a
genius chip chip how's this making you
feel okay time dude it's okay
oh lewb if you can make it further than
this chip you get ten smackeroonies hey
someone TP for a up here so we can watch
haven't you won money on this channel
before yeah I really wanna game chip
Caray has already won $10,000 this video
right here play the clip so you might
win another $10,000 he might literally
win $20,000 by playing Minecraft which
is crazy mmm
fight as long as you stand so chip bait
the big the first jump oh all right all
right here it is
if you're not saluting your turbo person
hold your salute three seconds here's a
great man okay for a you want $10,000 a
week ago and now you just want another
$10,000 what is going on I don't know
Frey is the first two-time champ
there's one two more times than Carl has
oh man me whoa you think you're better
than me friend is all you think it is
guys get in the server and that's it for
this video hit subscribe I'll see in the
next one